we've got some promising news in the
fight against the coronavirus pfizer
says new data out this morning confirmed
that an antiviral pill the drug maker
developed is highly effective at
treating covet 19. it says the pill can
reduce the risk of hospitalization or
death by 89 percent in high risk
unvaccinated adults if it's given within
three days of the first coveted symptoms
pfizer says that it submitted its data
to the fda for emergency use
authorization and if approved it could
become the first antiviral drug on the
market developed specifically to target
covet 19. the company made this
announcement one year to the day think
about this it was one year ago today
that we saw the first covet 19 vaccine
shot given here in this country i
remember that very well pfizer ceo
albert borla joins us now mr boiler it's
so good to see you what perfect timing
for us to have you here on this
particular day sounds like we have
another weapon in the cove at arsenal so
help us help us understand if you could
simply tell us how it works and how you
think it could change the change the
game in dealing with coved
thank you this is a treatment it's not
something that we use for prevention at
the states people that are getting sick
unfortunately some of them ending up in
hospitals or ending up dying with this
pill
we have now proved that instead of 10 of
them going to hospital only one will go
and frankly no one died in this study so
the mortality should be prevented at
very high levels as you said that was 89
within three days but the very very
impressive it is when you gave it also
five days of the symptom onset was 88 so
the same results
it was
it's a game changer
yeah well we like the term game changer
when dealing with covet how soon do you
think mr borla it could be available
i think it can be available uh this
month
first of all the first thing that needs
to happen is that fda
will provide an approval or
authorization emergency use
authorization in this case i think they
have a very high sense of urgency but i
can't talk about them because they need
to take all the time they need to review
the data and
make their own decision once they make a
decision we have already sent product in
the united states so the product is
waiting here we have already been in
very deep discussions with american
government how we will start immediately
distribution and i believe everything
will go well once it is approved
mr borla you call it a game changer and
looking at the data i can i can see why
but i'm curious what makes you think
that the pill will exist parallel to the
vaccine as opposed to as a replacement
for the vaccine there's a lot of
americans maybe 40
who don't want that vaccine is this
going to encourage them to be like hey
you know what we don't need it i'll just
take the pill
there is a risk to happen with what you
said and that would be a very big
mistake vaccines are needed people needs
to prevent getting sick they should not
take chances that they may not get
seriously sick because there is a pill
that could treat them people should
prevent and not also should prevent the
disease from them should prevent the
disease from the people that they love
if they get it they are the ones that
give it to their parents their
grandparents the kids so people need to
do the vaccinations but unfortunately
there will be cases that of course
disease and now this is the big news
that when we have covered surges usually
what is happening is that hospitals are
overwhelmed
people are in icus hospitals need to
change their normal procedures sometimes
they postpone elective surgeries it's a
very big problem for the health care
system right now with this field
instead of 10 going there only one nine
will stay at home and hopefully nobody
will die this is a very big deal
albert how will this pill hold up
against the variant omicron
we believe very very very well in fact
the latest studies that we did in the
lab where we tested the sensitivity the
sensitivity of omicron is even higher
than the other
variants it is extremely high against
all variants but omega is one of the
highest that doesn't mean that we have a
hundred percent proof but it is we we
have a strong strong strong strong
strong belief that
omicron will not be affected we will see
the same spectacular results with
omitron as we saw with delta and other
variants
how would you assess how far we've come
in a year i think it's interesting that
you're here on a year anniversary i know
you really worked with your team and
really pressed your team how far would
you assess we've come in a year and what
concerns you what concerns you a year
later what concerns you most a year
later
it's amazing first of all and you
pointed out that in the beginning the
timing right so exactly in the day
that we administered the first vaccine
now we have the confirmation of a 90
percent 89 bill
i think a lot has accomplished right now
i'm really optimistic because we have
very important very powerful tools at
our hands what worries me is like
everyone that
the whole thing has been politicized
and
the disease the masks the vaccines
less the pills or the treatments but
that's unfortunate and happen all over
the world not only here
and
there is also a number of people that
they are afraid of the vaccine and
we're still working on those people
do you think the reality is that we have
got to figure out a way to learn to live
with covet isn't that our reality as we
sit here today we gotta
live with it i truly believe that
this pandemic will not end by the viral
disappearing the influenza virus didn't
disappear but we live with it there is
no problem we don't have to change our
lives because there is uh
there is an illness influenza that will
happen with covet as well the virus will
stay for years is my belief but you will
be able to control it and have you can
go back to normal life
because we have very powerful tools that
give me the optimism
like gail said we love hearing that this
could be a game changer yeah you shall
see albert boiler thank you so much